so we have depicted here is a unit
circle centered at point a and the point
b lies on the circle and then we drop
the perpendicular with from from point b
to point d point d lies on the positive
x-axis and they form this triangle a b d
and they tell us that angle b-a-d angle
bad it has a measure of pi over 4
radians what i want to do in this video
is use our knowledge of trigonometry and
use our knowledge of triangles in order
to figure out several things so the
first thing we want to figure out is
what's the measure of angle what's the
radian measure what's the radian
measure
measure
of
angle
abd of angle a
b d actually let's just do that first
and then i'll talk about the other
things that we need to think about
so i assume you've paused the video and
tried to do this on your own so let's
think about what abd would be we know
two of the angles of this triangle so if
you know two of the angles of this
triangle you should be able to figure
out the third now what might be a little
bit unfamiliar we're used to saying that
the sum of the interior angles of a
triangle add up to 180 degrees but now
we're thinking in terms of radians so we
could say that the sum of the angles of
a triangle add up to instead of saying
180 degrees 180 degrees is the same
thing as pi radians so this angle plus
that angle plus that angle are going to
add up to pi
so let's just say that this right over
here
let's say that let's just say measure of
angle abd
in radians plus pi over 4
plus pi over 4
plus this is a right angle what would
that be in radians well a right angle in
radians a 90 degree angle in radians is
pi over 2 radians so plus pi over 2
when you take the sum of them the
interior angles of this triangle they're
going to add up to pi radians which is
of course the same thing as 180 degrees
and now we can solve for the measure of
angle abd
measure of angle a
b d
is equal to
pi
minus pi over 2
minus pi over 4. i just subtracted these
two from both sides so this is going to
be equal to let's see we could put a
common denominator of four then this is
four pi over four
this is minus two pi over four
and this of course is minus pi over 4.
so 4 minus 2 minus 1
is going to get us to 1. so this is
going to give us 2 pi over 4. so the
measure of angle abd is actually the
same as the measure of angle bad it is
pi
it is pi over 4 so that angle right over
there is pi over 4. now what does that
help us
with
so if we know that this is pi over 4
and that is pi over 4 radians and once
again we know this is a unit circle so
we know the length of segment a a b
that this which is a radius of the
circle or is the radius of the circle is
length one
what else do we know about this triangle
can we figure out the lengths of segment
a d and the length of segment db
well sure
because we have two base angles that are
that have the same measure that means
that the corresponding sides are also
going to have the same measure that
means that this side is going to be
congruent to that side i can reorient it
in a way that it might make it a little
bit more a little easier to realize if
we were to flip it over
if we were to not completely flip it
over but if we were to make it look like
this
so the triangle we could make it look
like
let me make it a little look a little
bit
a little bit more like
this actually i want to make it look
like a right angle though
so my triangle let me make it look like
there you go
so
if this is d
if this is d this is b
this is a this is our
right angle now this is pi over 4
radians and this is also pi over 4
radians when your two base angles are
the same you know you're dealing with an
isosceles triangle and isosceles
and but because they're not all the same
you know it's not equilateral if all if
all of the angles were the same this
would be equilateral but this is an
isosceles non-equilateral triangle so if
your base angles are the same then you
also know that the corresponding sides
are going to be the same these two sides
are same this is a this is an isosceles
triangle and so how does that help us
figure out the lengths of the sides well
if you say that if you say that this
side has length x that means that this
side has length x if this side has
length x then this side has length x and
now we can use the pythagorean theorem
we could say that x squared
this x squared plus this x
squared is equal to the hypotenuse
squared is equal to 1 squared
or we could write that 2x squared is
equal to 1 or that x squared is equal to
1 over 2
or
just taking the principal root of both
sides we get x is equal to one over the
square root of two and a lot of folks
don't like having a
radical in the denominator they don't
like having a rational number in the
denominator so we could rationalize it
and not the denominator by multiplying
by the square root of 2
over the square root of 2 which would be
let's see the numerator we'll have the
square root of 2 and in the denominator
we're just going to have square root of
2 times square root of 2 is just 2. so
we've already been able to figure out
several interesting things we're able to
figure out a measure of angle abd in
radians we were able to figure out the
lengths of segment ad and the length of
segment bd
now what i want to do is figure out what
are the sine cosine and tangent of pi
over 4 radians given all of the work
that we have done
so let's first think about what is the
sine
let me do this in a color do it in
orange given all the work we've done
what is the sine of pi over 4 radians
and i encourage you once again pause the
video think about the unit circle
definition of trig functions and
think about what this is
well the unit circle definition of trig
functions and this angle this pi over 4
radians is forming an angle with the
positive x-axis and where its terminal
ray intersects the unit circle
the x and y-coordinates of this point
are what specify the cosine and sine so
the coordinates of this point are going
to be
are going to be the cosine of pi over 4
radians is the x coordinate and the sine
of pi over 4 radians is the y coordinate
sine of pi over 4. so what's the y
coordinate going to be if we want the
sine of pi over 4
well it's going to be this length right
over here which is the same thing as
this length which is the length of x
which is square root of 2
over 2.
now what is the cosine of pi over 4
and once again i encourage you to pause
the video to think about it what's this
x coordinate what's the x coordinate the
x coordinate is this distance right over
here which is once again going to be x
which is square root of 2
over 2.
now
what is the tangent
of pi over 4 going to be
well the tangent of pi over 4 is just
sine of pi over 4
over cosine of pi over 4.
now both of these are the exact same
thing they're both square root of 2 over
2. so you're going to have square root
of 2 over 2 divided by square root of 2
over 2 well that's just going to give
you 1. and that also makes sense because
remember the tangent of this angle is a
slope of this line and we see the slope
for every x we move in the horizontal
direction we move x up so our change in
y over change in x
is essentially x over x which is equal
to 1.